the feminists become being anti-men
shoes
study of human behavior red bullies
anti-womeness because even if
he's the comments left by red pill men
it can never be a rational debate it
will never be like I disagree with this
it's like tell her where's her makeup
from where's her and it's like so angry
where you can't have rational
conversations with red pill man you I'll
watch these comments today
that sounds like a you problem because I
have rational conversations
that's why our conversations with red
pill men and if they were anti-missile
never stop interrupting me stop
interrupting me and if they were
anti-misogynistic then I would have an
issue but they're not but you you say
that you speak their language very few
people say po where's your ring very few
men were so well
wrong wrong I was just on an interview
yeah I was grilled for two hours
straight by a freaking blue pill betta
set I'm talking about red pills listen
listen listen to me what I'm saying I've
had conversations with red pill guy
anti-marriage guy anti this this this
this guy never had an issue the only
issue I've ever had and and got grilled
on this that stuff was by blue pill dude
exactly what my point is Redfield men
will never come for you because you
speak their language but if you try and
tell them rational debates and give them
logical answers that aren't regurgitated
Kevin Samuel videos or anything they'll
come for you they really will and that's
right it's not constructive that's not
true because when I started I wasn't red
pill
I have two years I have I have two years
worth of videos the first time I watched
canvas Samuels I did not say nice things
about I was not a fan and I never had
issues with misogyny I never had issues
with like women haters I just said the
only thing they debate is ideas I mean I
mean they might troll you a little bit
if anything but you won't experience it
because you don't speak no and opposite
language you're not listening to what
I'm saying when I started on YouTube
I did not agree with everything I had
many did you as I said twenty thousand
twenty thousand and now you're on I have
more now what's 600 000 what's your
point but you keep moving the goal
because you said you speak their
language I said when I didn't speak
their language I had no issue so it's a
you problem because even even when I
when I did not speak their language I
had no issues well I can speak from my
experience when I say any video that
agrees with men like if I say women
shouldn't dress like this or feminism is
this I'll get the men raving reposting
moment you call them out and say no no
also men need to do this just to create
a rational balance dialogue they turn
into the male equivalent of feminists
where they lose all their rationality
and become emotional and they'll start
making personal remarks the exact same
thing they accuse women of doing they go
to being personal when they don't have a
lot of logical argument does the comment
section roast yes yeah but it doesn't
bother me that they Rose me they can say
whatever they want but the reality is it
only happens when I don't talk their
language and they display the same
emotional dysregulation as a feminist
they claim to hate the feminists that
say I hate women all men are trash the
red pill men when you don't speak their
language it displayed the exact level of
femininity irrationality and personal
remarks that we are always told that
women do I mean I just think it's silly
to go on the internet and not expect to
give bad comments so so on both sides
yeah on both sides so it's like did you
get hate comments does that does that
mean the whole red pill movement when
I've when I I'm the one who knows all of
the people that lead the space I'm the
one who's met them you're basing your
experience off of the comment section no
I'm basing it off the red pill community
that I see and what I find okay have you
met any of them in person other than me
so I'm saying with the red pill men that
you that you're talking about have you
met any yeah I've met any any any
content creators no content creators
I've been in contact with a few but
online and stuff but not in person
because they're usually American okay so
so you haven't even dealt with them and
you're making an assumption about them
but I can make an assumption based on
like you haven't dealt with feminists or
whales or [__] that but you can make an
assumption because they come for you
right I can make an assumption based on
the ones I've talked to in real life
where I was attacked but I've never I've
never communicated with feminists but
I've had feminists contact my workplace
and then try and get me fired I've had
feminists that have come from my parents
photo phone numbers and address so I can
make an assumption on them even though I
haven't met them in real time because I
live I've never met a feminist no I'm a
feminist yeah you met me and yeah but I
could still make assumptions on the
extremities of both red pill and
feminism because I experienced both of
them in real life but I've had my job
contacted I've had my boss call me in
and say this we've been sent this I've
had feminist posts repost my videos it's
like a crazy person rather than like a
person that has but the extremities on
each end are as bad as each other it's
as bad as each other red pill men are
the male equivalent of feminists when
they go to that extreme because what
happens with both of them is that they
forget to incorporate their own
experiences and they just have this
mindset of hate and anger and they've
not even listening to the argument they
just want to show so you're a woman or
don't ask a woman what a man needs don't
ask a woman about outfit no no what
speak rationally have a rational
discourse I mean the the point they're
making about don't ask a woman like what
you're talking about dating advice
General like you can't ask a woman when
the alpha is can't ask what high
evaluate well you can't ask a woman is
what what are you talking about you can
ask humans what humans do yeah I mean
you can ask but
usually they talk about dating advice
like don't take dating advice from women
it's like are you asking the fishermen
that's usually what they're talking
about but then wouldn't that also apply
then don't ask men for men advice
because you don't ask the fish like when
not be don't ask men for men well see no
because men have had to listen to what
women have to say for years women don't
have to listen to what men have to say
that's why it's so triggering a lot of
times when I say things on this podcast
like men know what we want because
they've had to listen to us for the last
20 30 years
um
but okay I'll I'll be honest um can we
Define like red pill and blue pill
because I mean I'm just thinking like
ibuprofen and Viagra I have no idea
it sounds like
um
people that do you know do you remember
menism it sounds like it's that versus
feminism is it is that right is that is
that no I mean red pill is apraxiology
it's a study of human behavior that's
what it is okay but what is it in real
world because feminism is equal rights
but really in the real world feminism
how was the how are the masses perceived
yeah right now so how is it in real time
how does the study of like human
behavior correlate to to the like this
topic
as in like how does it apply to dating
and advice and all of that what's the
dynamic there
how does it apply to date well so like
gosh there's so much that goes into it
but it's just like women so for example
they study women like and why women do
the things they do so like women look
for different things at different ages
so like for example women one thing they
talk about is a woman's sexual market
value so like when she's at her highest
and what she would look for when she's
the most attractive to men so for
example
women in their early 20s tend to look
for looks well women in their late 20s
to 30s tend to look for security and
that so they would say like these are
the examples and yeah
what makes some of them so triggered
where they just spew out hate and to any
woman that has an opinion I don't know
any content creators that do that um I
can't help the comment section so I
think a lot of people like I think the
difference is like fresh and Fit I would
say Marlon I would say is very angry
yeah no I don't know I don't think so
actually
um I mean he just people don't like his
tone and I think women have an issue
with his tone but no I I don't think he
hates women by any means does he come
across as somebody who has successful
relationships with women and can have a
marriage and a stable relationship with
women yeah I think you could I don't
think he comes across it yeah I mean I
would disagree I mean I don't think they
hate women
um no I don't think that you don't think
he insults the uh like the women's
mindset in general or anything like that
so he might say something like um well
you're 20 once a woman's more than 25
she's got no value and if you haven't
got a ring you haven't got an opinion
women can't Define high value blooming
can't Define Alpha men women don't have
uh can't solve any of men's problems men
women
let me start with the 20th okay because
you're giving me a bunch so what was the
first one you said 20 women over 25 yeah
they have no value yeah I mean I don't
think that's misogynistic but no every
age has a cut off so every guy is like
your mom has no value
yeah I've talked to my mom about this in
the sexual Marketplace nah good luck my
mom on the dating scene
like he's talking about it's not not
personal words it's sexual market value
so I mean most guys will date a girl for
25 though she looks good true true so
maybe maybe he's pickier he prefer girls
under 25 the point is women under over
the age of 25 typically we've had our
heart broke Hearts broken and men have
to deal with that so it's easier to get
with a younger girl who hasn't hasn't
had drama okay do you want do you want a
girl with more trauma or less trauma guy
well I didn't ask you then more trauma
or less trauma less trauma more trauma
less trauma
okay so so so this is this is as women
we listen and say I understand that
instead of trying to argue and tell you
them what they want yeah and I'm not
going to be offended is my mom gonna do
well on The Dating Market with 10 kids
I'm not under dating my of course no but
I didn't mean it in sexual I meant in
general as a value as a person but uh I
can speak for somebody when I was 21 and
then going to 25. I genuinely think I
did more reflection and became less
traumatized as I was 10 25. I personally
felt like I was far I was so volatile at
21. I was so impulsive at 21. as I
became old I became less of a burden to
a man but we're not talking about you
we're talking about in general humans
yeah we're more emotional and volatile
I'm saying like in general we're not
like he doesn't know your specific story
and so so if if we're talking to the men
and the men like Andrew Tate said
something similar or women over the age
of 2019 and they're and they're saying
nothing he gave the age of 19. and he
and if they're saying we prefer the
women younger yeah like why are we to
tell them what they want no no you I
think it should be with a younger woman
I really do think younger is more
beautiful and especially when it comes
to having kids but it's also saying
things like oh women can't Define what
makes them mad women have no definition
of what makes an apple well
biological terms
no the point they're making though is
that like for a man to be Alpha to be
high value he has to be selected by
other men first like other men have to
respect him first but for the women can
come in and so that that's that's what
they're talking about someone
disqualified for realizing or not being
able to make because you can look at a
monkey and decide which one's Alpha
you'd have to be a mother other men have
other high-value men have to recognize
him as a part of the group so so I mean
we're kind of interchanging high value
in Alpha but but when it comes to high
value men that's what they're talking
about yeah it's the other high value the
other no because of the other high value
men have to recognize him as part of the
group and can a low value man realize a
high value man I think most men when
they walk into a room they can they can
just naturally tell
it's definitely a hierarchy and women
as well they call us a cap yeah we can
tell when something's high enough you
think so
how do they interact with us yeah
exactly and then how did the Tinder
swindler get so successful if women why
do you think women and historically like
the the fathers have been involved women
suck at picking man we do I'm looking
I'm as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible